if you wanted to teach boxing out you  would show your players that clip  right there harden loses the ball and  mellow gets it ahead for mccollum  minutes to play westbrook drive  to the corner tucker it's blocked  carmelo anthony there defensively  the intensity level of both of these  teams  down the stretch here has been  incredible trent to three  he's got it gary trent jr  trapped him these last two times down  the floor lillard turns the corner  kicks it out extra feed mellow  got a three  [Applause]  carmelo anthony a big one from downtown  talked about how last game they shot 61.  now here's lillard  kicking it out and they move it around  and find the open man covington just a  little bit